i always feel like with the ovo thing
right it's like do you ever feel like
there's like a gift and a curse of being
with ovo because at the end of the day
drake is the biggest artist in the world
he's one of the most talented artists in
the world
um
and i feel like
i appreciate his ear for who he signs to
the label because there's always like
high
i mean i wouldn't say always
but for the most part high artistic
integrity when i think of like magic
jordan and you guys um
i feel like he also
is allowing people to develop like
artist development's like a real thing
of ovo if that makes sense but at the
same time that takes time and when
you're signed to drake people probably
expect you to just come out swinging
with like you know [ __ ] hit records
and drake features and all this [ __ ]
rick is
people look at
his
what he does for features and what he
does for the the label
as two separate things and they expect
the same things i think it's different i
think him jumping on a record versus him
signing you
his mental approach to that is just
completely different i think like he
might find a record and be like cool i'm
gonna just
hop on this wave come on come on there
drop this yeah drop this elevate this
record and they call it the drake stimmy
pack yeah the stemi right yes whereas i
think with artists that that he's
involved with you know the business of
signing i think that he likes to
be like
this person's dope give them give them
what they need
this person's dope you know give them
what they need
versus the approach that he takes when
he's just like i'm jumping on a rock
right i just feel like it's like dope
because i you'll see like artist
development happening at ovo like you
know what i'm saying like it's not
always like the the cheat code is like
let me just get on a song
knowing what that's going to do that's
also the easiest way for people to fail
i mean because if you take an artist
that's not in
the drake position right
you give them the drake
and then
and
then insert name here
who's no longer relevant exactly you
know and that's why we've always been
really appreciative of the way that he's
embraced things and let us kind of
develop on our own
path right figure that out at the same
time like
we still can go back and forth with
records or ideas and that's how we ended
up on the views album or that's how he's
had songs that he's written and he'll
throw it to us and be like yo what do
you think of this record you want to do
something with it or you know there's
always been that freedom but there's
never the pressure to feel like you guys
don't have to do
the drake way of doing right so you
don't have to do it
the way
the traditional like label process would
be not only that but i think it helps
every artist on the label kind of
own
own their brand
right that's smart yeah because i think
that division like we have our we
definitely have our own brand and your
own cult following following our fans
it's independent of everything he's
independent of anything yeah so i i love
that we've been able to to to to have
the space to do that and to be you know
successful in doing that what was his
reaction when he heard this record we
haven't we haven't talked to anybody
since we dropped
jesus
bro we literally
in the tunnels just trying to get this
album done so justice over there doesn't
kill us um
but we literally haven't talked to
anybody sent no we don't we literally
locked in the studio
cooked up and popped our head out to
drop this and even this record why we
popped our head up to drop this is
because we've been inviting people to
the studio just to you know hear things
yeah and
every time we played that record the
whole room would burst into argument
for like half an hour an hour time so
we're like yo what is happening and
every guy felt like liberated some women
are like yeah you know what i get that
you know it's honest some girl's like oh
it's a bop some girls are like
i'm triggered you know i'm mad oh it's
the trigger you know
there's the and we're just like yo what
is happening this has never happened
with a song like this so because of that
we just
we got to get this thing out this is
also the first album that we've done
outside of toronto
you guys were you guys doing atlanta
yeah everything's been in jail
yeah
it's amazing